Це дерево – її нинішнє помешкання.
Ми назвемо цю дівчину Сашою. Вона просить не розголошувати
її справжнього імені, бо мешкати на дереві
на дванадцятиметровій висоті –
незаконно.
Півроку тому дівчина переїхала в Гамбахський ліс
на заході Німеччини. Таке життя може мати
серйозні наслідки для 21-річної активістки.
Це наш протест. Звичайно, круто жити на деревах
і бути у єднанні з природою, але це
форма протесту. Ми розуміємо, що поліція може затримати нас.
Нас не просто виселять звідси –
йдеться про арешт та ув’язнення.
Ув’язнення за те, що вони намагаються захистити ліс
від його власника – енергетичного концерну RWE.
Під лісом – поклади бурого вугілля.
Мета активістів – завадити знищенню лісу
та видобутку вугілля. Загалом тут, на деревах
постійно мешкають до тридцяти молодих людей.
Вони знімають на відео свою боротьбу за збереження дерев.
Ось – сутичка зі службою безпеки RWE,
яка намагається виселити активістів.
Це мав бути мирний протест, але ситуація
поступово змінилася.
Енергетичний концерт заявляє, що володіє усіма правами
на видобуток корисних копалин.
У цьому RWE підтримує і німецький уряд. Згідно з планом,
розвідка покладів в нижньорейнському вугільному басейні
триватиме до 2050-го року.
Люди, які сидять на деревах у Гамбахському лісі,
пробудуть там недовго. План відкритого видобутку
вже затверджено. Захист клімату – одна з цілей
енергетичної політики Німеччини, але водночас слід
гарантувати й те, що такі густонаселені
індустріальні країни як Німеччина
будуть забезпечені надійним та доступним джерелом
енергії.
Супротив, який чинять активісти –
майже символічний, адже більшу
частину Гамбахського лісу давно вирубали.
Замість нього – величезний  котлован глибиною 400 метрів.
Через поклади вугілля зникли і багато прилеглих сіл,
мешканці яких були змушені виїхати.
Курт Классен виріс тут.
Він аж ніяк не радий тому, як змінився його рідний край. Тож фермер
об'єднався з активістами у боротьбі з RWE -
і пустив їхнє наметове містечко на своє поле.
Найперший легальний спосіб боротьби – через суд.
Є багато способів, але один я це не потягну, тому був змушений об’єднати свої сили
з активістами. Спеціально чи ні,
але в нас встановився розподіл праці. Вони забезпечують
розголос, а я – даю аргументи.
Поки що ані судова тяганина, ані акції протесту
не зупинили знищення лісу.
Але Саша з друзями не опускає рук.
Для них це більше, ніж просто видобуток вугілля.
Це боротьба проти експлуатації –
як людей, так і природи.
І Гамбахський ліс – символ цього.